it was like I have this bones g7 h6
against h5 pone so my g7 pone is a bit
yeah yeah and so my only chance to I
mean still will be lost but to to keep
keep on fighting is to put this pawn to
g5 but if I will play g5 immediately
he'll definitely take and pass off so I
play g6 which is looks completely stupid
because I don't really want to take on
h5 so he makes the move then I play g5
and it's still lost by the case it is I
mean some glimmer of hope after that yes
because he shouldn't take it on GC and
then I just shake him a little bit of a
poker with you oh yeah it was different
by far my best move is yes I think port
moment in the game and so you didn't
have joy in that game how did that
affect your mindset coming into today's
contest playing such a long game
physically it's draining or were you
thinking let me just take this one
slowly no but I wasn't taking it slowly
I mean I actually took it too fast so
fast then I could not stop but I mean
[Music]
this line okay I I think in my notes I
have this line written as a joke line I
mean it looks so bad for black just joke
line French defence joke line and yeah I
mean I looked at it and I thought maybe
okay at some point I will play it with
black but it looked so bad but actually
with white it's not that easy you could
have taken on e6 at one point only five
and if Rock age five didn't take on and
create green a true Kate chick and I
thought is no but I mean it still was
something I vaguely looked at and I
don't know from the black side it really
looked bad but I don't know I mean you
just didn't believe in his positions he
didn't look at it very deeply yeah
that's what I said I mean
you are not supposed to face drug
clients at such level I see sometimes
you do get to draw so far not a bad
start to the tournament what are your
feelings about your performance so far
no but what is funny is that I yesterday
played the number two player in the
world and today a plate number two
player is owned by different players you
know at least in Russia we have this
sort of jokes like for example son of my
father but not me obviously but another
one is more difficult let's say there is
a professor in the room and then a
person comes to the room who is the
father of the son of the professor how
is this possible I know the answer ok
you can should know that one to the
professor I think I've heard that one
before ok you should really know the
answer listen you should know come on
yeah the professor is a is a woman
exactly the professor is the mother of
the son of the professor exactly ok ok
gotcha gotcha yeah all right we gotta
get a little diagram of that up for
everybody so but good point
you played number 2 in the world and
they flip places in one day yes so you
drew number 2 number 2 in the world and
back-to-back days yeah you know in a
switch tournament but it's funny well
good point
a murderer I'm still number two yeah for
the moment but he's he might lose that
number to status tomorrow
not even to Dave Benavides right ok
notice it made ok to justice Alito's
well we appreciate it indeed so you so
you're doing well you got you gain some
rating points over the last couple of
days but still seven long rounds to go
yes all right well thank you very much
for joining us we appreciate the time
and the puzzles ensuring that Jennifer
is not the feminist that she thinks she
is
[Laughter]
Sasha just comment and to share
something with you at the opening
ceremony you're who you were mentioning
that you felt a little uncomfortable
being in the hall of fame and that there
should in fact be a Hall of Shame for
yourself and I just wanted to say that
there is a Hall of Fame I'm a founding
member and it would be great to have you
all the Hall of Shame because I have
done some horrible things in my life so
I just want to say that I would be very
happy to entertain you as a founding
members from the hall of the member or
actually be inducted into the Hall of
Shame but yes today was no shame it was
a fine game and yesterday what a what a
struggle so good luck in your tournament
and don't think we love your interviews
so come visit us every day really you're
you're definitely a fan favorite thank
you and so now Jennifer where would you
like to turn our attention which game
I'd like to turn my raft Maurice he says
that I'm not offended